thank you I love you - preciate you
putting on this brave face because it's
a tough day John Hickenlooper has
dropped out of the presidential race it
was a huge blow to his supporter and but
he said he he just wants to go back to
what he does best
looping hick ins Trump has been tweeting
it about me and talking about me it is
rally so my anxiety level is very high
I'm hoping he'll get distracted by his
new plan I'm not making this up he wants
to buy Greenland and renamed it new
Ivanka he wants to buy he had to
Nuremberg rallies this week and the
highlight for me is that the one list
that he told a protester you have a
weight problem this is like mocking
virgins at comic-con
isn't it
really he pointed to a guy they said
that guy's got serious weight problem go
home and start exercising also pay your
taxes read a book and stay married but
he broke another norm this week when he
pressured another country Israel to not
let in two to Congress people this never
happened before I know if you saw the
story but congresswoman Rasheeda Talib
from Detroit I believe wanted to go to
the West Bank where her grandmother
lives and Trump told Israel they
shouldn't let her in so Israel not their
finest moment said she couldn't go and
then they got blowback so then she they
said she could go and then she got
blowback because she was gonna go so now
she says she's not gonna go it's so
confusing the racist at his rally don't
know what to chat
send her back don't send her back wait
I'm sorry
lock her up they're like what
and Trump never informed really about
any foreign country doesn't know a lot
about Israel when he went to the Wailing
Wall
he brought a harpoon and I don't
understand Trump's followers on this
kind of stuff because they hate
foreigners they hate other religions and
they hate people who are think they're
so smart but they love the Jews I guess
you'll think about that one on the way
home but what Trump the financial genius
is driving the economy over the cliff
have you seen that I mean for years
everyone at the world's economies has
been doing [ __ ] great growing nobody
they said could screw it up
enter Trump saying hold my beer
his new slogan is make America Atlantic
City again no well did you see what
happened in the stock market this week I
mean I spent more time gasping for
breath in Jeffrey Epstein
owing into applause you know we do it
here but yes Jeffrey Epstein was found
dead in his jail cell they say America
can't do anything anymore yes and
Attorney General William bar he has
called for a thorough investigation to
which he has already written the summary
I don't get that of course the
conspiracy theories are abounding
already because this Jeffrey Epstein guy
knew everybody at Clinton Trump Prince
Andrew Dershowitz oh it was a who's who
of this Epstein guy was a weirdo I mean
besides the pedophilia besides the sex
island besides the plane the Lolita
Express they called it hit a ranch in
New Mexico did you read this I'm not
making this up where he was gathering
scientists and nubile young women and a
plan to repopulate the earth from his
spawn and Schwarzenegger said or you
could just hop on the made
[Applause]
of course of course
trumped the conspiracy there is
retweeting that the clintons killed
Jeffrey Epstein I mean of all the
right-wing conspiracy theories that have
been going around this is the stupidest
the idea that the Clintons go around
killing their enemies first of all it
makes them look cool nobody ever accused
Mitt Romney of murdering his way to the
top
[Laughter]
finally a congressman Congressman Steve
King not Stephen King the author he's
the second scariest Steve King
congressman's heat this guy out does him
selves he said humanity this week this
was his court humanity not a quote but
I'm paraphrasing humanity might not
exist if not for rape and incest
throughout human history and then his
sister bolted out of the room
you